[موسيقى]
كان لفرنسا دور في عمليات الاجلاء من
السودان اكثر من الف شخص تم نقلهم الى دول
مجاوره من بينهم سودانيون واجانب من
ثمانين جنسيه مختلفه وفي جوابه على سؤالنا
في مؤتمر صحفي اكد القائد الفرنسي في
عمليات الاجلاء في جيبوتي الدقه العاليه
التي تطلبتها هذه المهمه
عمليه الاجلاء كانت معقده لذا كان علينا
التفكير بكل التفاصيل للتنسيق بشكل جيد
لذلك لم نواجه صعوبات كبيره في شبكتنا
التي عملت بشكل جيد وهذا ما ساعد على ان
تكون الامور سلسه خلال التعاوننا في فريق
فرنسا بين الوزارات والفاعلين المختلفين
وهو ما ساهم بنجاح العمليه
استقبلت فرنسا سابقا اعدادا كبيره من
اللاجئين السودانيين الذين تصدروا قائمه
اللجوء لديها عام 2016 واليوم انضم الى
هؤلاء وفي دون جدد هربا من صراع مستمر لم
يهدا بعد بين القوات العسكريه المتنازعه
في الخرطوم
ريثما تضع الحرب اوزارها في السودان اجبر
المئات من السودانيين على ترك ديارهم
مكرهين بعضهم قادته الاقدار للوصول الى
هنا والبعض الاخر توزع على دول المجاوره
بعد عمليات اجلاء واسعه شاركت فيها دول
عده ومن بينها فرنسا من غرب فرنسا زينه
عدي العربيه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات